تقضي هذه الطالبه ساعات طويله خلف شاشه
الكمبيوتر لتصميم حياه افتراضيه على كوكب
المريخ حلم يراود لنا النابلسي احدى
المشاركات في مخيم الفضاء التدريبي بجامعه
كاوست والذي تنظمه الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء
بالشراكه مع وكاله ناسا الامريكيه عمري
سبع سنين وانا كنت مره احب الفضاء كان
عندي فضول واجد عنهم الفرصه جتني اللي هي
كانت حقه كاوست فعلى طول اخذت الفرصه
الحمد لله والحمد لله دخلت ومره استفدت
منها الحمد لله ومره كانت تجربه جميله
واشوف نفسي بالمستقبل ان شاء الله مهندسه
فضاء ان شاء الله الفضاء مو كلهم اكتشف
وعندي فضول اني اكتشف زياده عنه فيمكن هذا
اللي خلاني مره مره احبه وخصوصا الثقب
الاسود لانه مو مره مكتشف عنه كثير مائه
طالب وطالبه من مواهب السعوديه
التحقوا بالبرنامج التدريبي المقامي على
ايدي متخصصين في مجالات العلوم والتقنيه
والهندسه والفنون والرياضيات
وبمشاركه نخبه رواد الفضاء المشهورين
عالميا من وكاله ناسا هو بناء مستوطنات
على في الفضاء مستوطنات مستدامه في الفضاء
سواء على كوكب المريخ او في الفضاء ومحطات
الفضائيه المختلفه المستوطنات هذه قد تضم
انتقال قد تنقل طرق التنقل طرق الاكل طرق
الشرق طرق المعيشه التعايش التواصل ايضا
فهمتهم ان يضعوا ان يكونوا او ينشئوا هذه
المستوطنات
هدفنا تحفيز الشباب بالعلوم والتكنولوجيا
في وظائفهم ومنحهم فرصا اكثر في السعوديه
في مجال التعليم فكرتنا تحفيز الطلبه
للدخول في المجالات العلميه والتكنولوجيه
لدينا تقريبا 100 طالب وطالبه وهذا الع دد
من المؤكد انه سيتضاعف مستقبلا يعد مخيم
الفضاء التدريبي الاول من نوعه في
السعوديه
ويهدف لخلق نافذه من الفرص للشباب السعودي
من خلال التبني المبكر للمواهب في مجالات
العلوم والتقنيه والهندسه والفنون وعلم
الفلك والفضاء من جامعه الملك عبد الله
للعلوم التقنيه سلطان السلمي العربيه